I ran three times and you learn a lot I
think it's what pissed me off so much
and how I fell into kind of radio and
podcasting because I got so aggravated
about the system and what Tim saying is
right I mean people who have very
mercenary me first kind of power hungry
attitudes do very well I'll never forget
being in a Capitol Hill Club and I'm
running and it's the first time like
we're they're my first Senate race
nobody took us seriously we won the
Primary by like some Act of God like I
ran for Senate the first time out of the
shoot we won the Republican primer it
was like the weirdest thing against 10
people and we you know by a sliver but
the second time it was kind of serious
like people thought gosh this guy can
because we wound up raising like a good
chunk of money but I'm in the Capitol
Hill Club and I'm with this uh I don't
know some group or something like that
and it was a was a strange thing they
sent out a questionnaire before you meet
with them and long and short of it it's
about a patent thing like first to fall
versus first to invent like something so
esoteric like only really like a limited
number of people care about it and I had
a very specific stance on it because it
mattered to me like I researched and did
the homework on all the issues and I'll
never forget them like almost kind of
implying like hey you know if you say
the opposite you know and I thought you
know how many people probably just told
them yes for a cheap campaign donation
because they don't care like no one's
even going to notice and I remember
walking out I'm not I'm trying to like
virtue signal anyone I mean I'm a sinner
like but I I like anyone else but I
wasn't doing that like because I knew
once you once you kind of once you sold
a little bit of your skin the pound the
flesh was next and I'm like I'm not
doing it and I walked out and I was like
nah man like that's my position I
appreciate you meeting with me I hope
you'll reconsider later on but I'm not
doing squat I'm not selling on anything
and then when I ran you know we were in
The General
you know against this guy in this
congressional district Delaney who since
left he ran for president left they had
this drone cat now
but uh you know I remember everyone
telling me Oh listen you need to
moderate you know you need to moderate
it's it's a it's a d plus six District
No Republicans gonna win as a
conservative you know if you just like
don't mention abortion or anything like
that
and I got to tell you man this is why I
think focus groups and politics are full
of bullshitters now because everything
they told me was fake I never changed
the damn thing we lost by one point
everyone else who ran lost by 15. so I
don't believe any of that you know I was
sitting in a group after Mitt Romney
lost to Obama down in DC this group I
was a part of uh is Groundswell Group
which was good people and it was just
like this focus group guy in there and
he's like don't ever mention immigration
again we're never gonna win these guys
are so stupid Trump literally runs on
build the wall and wins Pennsylvania for
the first time ever that's why I I just
good candidates find a way to overcome
with good messaging if you can stick it
on a damn Wheaties box and explain it to
someone you can win the problem is like
Tim said you get so many mercenary jerks
they're just terrible Messengers they're
just really bad and that's why I think
the Republican party without the defense
of the media we just continue to lose I
think good people don't want to do bad
things to win like you were saying you
don't compromise your values how do you
win against someone you're playing a
game of Monopoly I'll put it this way
and the guy you're playing against keeps
pulling money out of the bank and
sticking his pocket and you're like hey
you can't do that and he's like no it's
fine how do you win against somebody
when they're just like I'm gonna keep
doing no matter what you do you're
actually playing against the people that
are drawing the board on the table and
like how do you win when someone can
just rewrite the complete structure of
the board itself like Kennedy tried John
Kennedy yeah you know he said out loud
I'm gonna change the structure of the
board guys and they're like no we're
going to rewrite the board so that
you're dead
you got an establishment
Democrats and Republicans and they work
together they do not like actual
politicians so what I end up seeing is
you get a trump and why do people like
Trump so much is because he's finally
somebody who he's talked a long time
about running and saying he wouldn't do
it remember that interview back in the
day with I think it was Oprah and he's
like you know I wouldn't run but if I
did hear the things that I would focus
on and he finally decides he is going to
run and it it feels like I think to a
lot of people it's the first time
someone who should run is actually
running despite his his crass
personality you know he's a guy who is
not supposed to be the politician the
politicians all wear the same suits
they'll talk the same way they all
Pander to the same same in the same ways
Hillary Clinton shows up in you know
whatever state with a fake southern
accent AOC shows up to a rallying as a
fake Puerto Rican Latina thing
it's fake
Trump
sure he might be rude but people kind of
feel like
we keep asking for people to run for
office who are real people who actually
care
and they don't want to do it why would
you it's it's torture you go fighting
that mission this environment it's the
system isn't built right at the moment
with all this technology that we still
have to like mail pieces of paper across
the world and hope that it lands in a
box and gets counted and that they're
just going to tell us the answer and we
have to believe they're they're what
they tell like that's 1870 technology
and and why would I want to be part of a
system that is about 100 disagree with
you you're totally wrong totally wrong
again I got to tell you back in the day
there were much less people and there
were physical bouts that could be
checked with tons of people standing
around staring now it's all code behind
the scenes you can't see you should be
able to see that right right so yeah but
I'm actually in it I'm actually arguing
you're on point with your own Point
we've long talked about how the problem
is proprietary private election systems
instead of publicly uh publicly
controlled open source ones so but but
the point I was getting to is not to to
open up the box of worms on do we trust
certain companies my point is simply the
quality of of candidate is very very low
it's been proven the people that are
leading the world are in the private
sector right now like politicians do
have some sway over the military
unfortunately or unfortunately okay but
really the people that are in control of
Earth are the people that own Google or
that Elon Musk people that are very very
wealthy they own the oil you know
they're they're you don't know their
names sometimes so I don't I think that
the real quality leaders aren't drawn to
politics they're drawn to business
because business is is more so
meritocratic so why is it that Dan
bongino and I both run these shows I
mean you tried to run for office instead
you have one of the biggest shows in the
world instead I I actually fair question
pretty good let me ask you directly like
you know how does it happen that you
wanted to get in office you wanted to
make that change instead you're doing
something different in terms of making
that change God loves him yeah I mean no
what I mean is you tried going the route
of being a Civic leader instead you
became an influential person that
happened by accident I mean I I you know
whole story of me running for office is
just crazy like I'm in my 12th year as
an agent I'm you know 13 years away from
retiring and the thing is I'm done with
the worst part of my career the
president's detail you think oh
everybody loves the presidency no no
they hate it they love going there
because it's distinguished like that's
the thing when you go to the Secret
Service we had like five thousand four
thousand agents a limited number of
people ever get there you know everybody
thinks everybody goes to the president's
detail it's actually a small number of
guys so if you get picked it's like a
big deal so I finished like I had done
lead advances I left at the top of my
game the rest of your career is pretty
much honestly you relitigating what you
did on the PPD presidential protective
division you know you live in reliving
Your Glory Days you know it's like high
school Harry telling that pass you
through in uh the fourth quarter to win
the game so I'm done I'm in the
Baltimore Field office life is good I'm
investigating cases which I love I was a
criminal investigator of the first but
you know I just love that stuff
and then uh you know I I just I saw
Obama win
and uh obviously I'm you know I'm
getting ready to
transfer to his details I'm on Bush's
detail and you know it's weird for us
the Secret Service because one night I
mean literally one night Bush walks out
of the bedroom and the next night it's
Obama like nothing changes for you it's
the same post
and um I had said
I had said to my wife about Obama I said
when I saw him give the speech at John
Kerry's nomination when John Kerry
remember he gave that speech it was
electric I said man this guy is going to
be big trouble huge trouble she
remembers it to this day and I knew the
country wasn't some really deep I
knew we were in trouble bad and I
emailed this local Anne Arundel County
I lived in Anne Arundel County Maryland
I emailed this guy found him online his
name is Jerry Walker I said hey Jerry
I'm just a guy man I saw this speech
last night the country's going to hell I
want to get involved he mailed me back
in like 20 minutes it was like 11
o'clock at night he said there's a local
Republican Club near you called the
elephant Club just show up and that's
that's how the whole thing started and
in just a couple months later I I looked
at my wife and I've been bothering her I
said I gotta leave I gotta leave I gotta
get out of here maybe six months later I
said I gotta go do something I got to do
something bigger than this man I can't
just watch the country go to I mean
I'm getting a paycheck you know
governments bills are always cleared for
me everyone else is getting you know
they're still dealing with the recession
and I felt like man this ain't right
like I'm I'm not I'm not like a a
citizen grifter here like I know my
job's important keeping this this cat
alive in the white house but I I gotta I
can't do this man so I said I think I
want to run for office my wife thought I
was nuts man she thought I was totally
bananas but to her credit she's always
willing to take a chance man she's like
all right you know what you want to run
we're at a cinco de mayo party in a
cul-de-sac I'm probably like 45 Tequilas
to the wind at that point who knows and
she looked at me goes you're really
going to want to do this right I said
yeah she said all right do it I resigned
I gave him two weeks notice and I left
and I jumped into U.S Senate race
everybody laughed they said look at this
idiot was this here I had no I had
nothing no money I had five emails a guy
had given me for local reporters you
know we won that primary we raised 1.2
million dollars wow we won that project
there's still stickers with your name on
it out here yeah this that race was
serious that was the next one the senate
race we got annihilated it was a
three-person racer got crushed the
independent actually spent more money
than all of us he spent seven million
bucks uh he he finished third I finished
second card and one but then we ran for
re-election here and that race was
serious man a lot of people were like
dude this guy's not screwing around man
like we would show up at the Brunswick
parade the Brunswick parade we had these
yellow shirts just the pictures are
still on my Instagram we'd show up with
150 people for a congressional race
walking down the street in yellow
t-shirts and everyone was like who the
hell is this guy and for people who
don't know Brunswick is not very big no
it's not big at all you look at the
pictures these thin streets you know
it's Hills all over we came down as a
picture of a yellow Prowler this
volunteer man had a yellow Prowler and
we had yellow shirts it looks like an
army invading Brunswick I'm telling you
man and you know what killed me in that
race
we would have won that race I got a job
and a job offer it was a pretty like
significant job offer because I was
filling in on radio while I was running
which is like a major No-No because you
know it's equal Time stuff how these
candidates didn't catch on is like crazy
but we were tearing it up on radio I get
a job offer like a month out from the
election yeah maybe two months whatever
about two months out and I'm like
what do I do I can't drop out and I'm
like we didn't think we were gonna win
and I'm like I made a I made a
commitment I made a promise but for like
a week I thought this thing through
because it was like life-changing for me
it was gonna happen and I did the right
thing I turned it down but I swear in
that week if we just would have knocked
on a few more doors we would have won
that race man I mean it was devastating
on Election night it was devastating we
we won on Election night was there were
the votes tallied on a machine with
proprietary software code I don't know
man but that Frederick City thing I told
you about still freaks me out that all
those people voted or claimed they
weren't citizens I was like what was it
about Obama freaked you out on that
first speech you heard
listen man it was kind of old school
collectivism repackaged with a bow under
the guise of like uh faux bravado
citizenry like oh look at me I'm so
pro-america I got this success story
what's your success story again
you're a community organizer you're just
to be clear like that so you but you get
how it was packaged in Liberty oriented
capitalism-based ideas like oh my gosh I
overcame what ex I'm sorry what did you
overcome again um you did you were a
community organizer like what exactly
did you do but I saw the guy I'm in I'll
never forget where I was I'm in the
Shelbourne Hotel in Manhattan because
I'm getting ready as a counter
surveillance agent for the Republican
National Convention which was in New
York which was after that so I'm
watching him give this speech on TV and
I'm thinking of every corrupt
destructive marxist-based politician in
human history what if they had the gift
of more than anything it's the gift of
the ability to expel carbon dioxide man
and talk and convince people that this
old idea they were packaging is
new again and I heard it I heard it new
again I heard it new again I heard old
school Marxist claptrap garbage packaged
in a way that even I'm listening going
damn that's good thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time